and did I tell you that the wrong
Williams did up after me when I did the
stand of New York what was he like well
I mean all this material is still about
like John Wayne Bobbitt like things that
happen like 50 years yeah but when he's
like it rising with the audience he's
really brilliant I'll see comics are
pictures of comics like in the cellar
where they're like jumping on collection
from the Raptors like Holly Mandel and
comic relief before comes out in a
shower on stage and just yells at the
archives from behind the shower curtain
on and then is like pushed away that's
his act you know yeah you know what I
mean like just being the wild and crazy
guy doesn't cut it anymore now it's very
stage I you dial his James people just
don't get up in the rafters as much as
that he's doing that's to Heaven I think
you know why is because Americans are
better yeah i guess i'm raising i
thought i already did I see it a
deserted island keira knightley or
Pamela Anderson I'm not attracted to
celebrities like I've seen Courtney Cox
in person and honestly the person she
reminded me most of was like Manute Bol
that's how skinny she was like remember
like Manute Bol will be running at
literally Manute Bol will be running
down the court when i was a kid and I
wouldn't worry that he was going to
collapse it
I'll bones and skin and that was how I
felt when I saw courtney cox like she
literally needed to be propped up by
someone while she has walketh any of
these girls if any of these eight girls
came up to you guys and like what's the
deal what's going on how you doing
tonight yes but let you do would you
turn inscrito I would totally rejoinder
that's true any good looking girl an
attractive cashier and Jessica Simpson
have both been shot with a crossbow
extra extra who do you go to first say
whether that in the fleshy part of the
thigh see that something celebrities
don't have welcomed over what do you
guys got you know I was gonna ask who
hears written a script and then I
remembered you guys both like almost
oldest group together yeah we often to
put madman that's a crazy guy who has a
weird accent and a shifty limp comics
are always wanted to write a stream it
helps to another person doing it with
you because I like motivate you and
that's what I found cuz i wrote a
screenplay with my friend what's it
about my screenplay yeah it's about
senior citizen police volunteers sounds
like a comedy dollar 75 to you it's a
dollars have you fun yeah you ever
notice that it costs the most for the
black man what about what about la
comics do you think that they're cheesy
there's such a big difference between
New York comics and Ollie comics right
now in New Yorker like that guy's a
writer and you can tell he's used to
performing on the stage that's the size
of this table these are performing to I
am for people who don't give up it's
tough it's tough pack to roll it la la
is you're ready they're just met in la
the stages are huge and they're doing
cartwheels and their closers they bring
out a guitar and they go marijuana you
know and then they put on a wig I don't
mean to give him a hard time because
they they're probably doing
definitely what's he ah we have in the
back part of my magazine there's this
thing called the classes you know people
come right in and what's going on with
them and it says on your plans so about
two months before my premium blend I was
like all right I'll tell him about my
premium blend so they finally printed
like two months after the premium blood
already Ayers and they changed the tents
of it so whereas i wrote I'm gonna be on
premium blend keep your eye out for it
it says it Matt goldich rights I was on
comedy said I don't know for me I
started most if i'm doing an hour the
first 2015 20 minutes is going to be in
probably you don't like to get over with
open it'll pull just sober I've heard
that which way you look strong yet yeah
I yeah I do that too but you if you're
doing in college you open with 10-15
minutes by the college we just go out
and if it doesn't work you just
improvise the bus you know I got my 45
there you can merge right into your act
have you ever closed too no laughs like
you're just eating in like 30 minutes I
closed it was my big joke my big
flourish nothing and I just go well
that's it ya done all your jokes you
don't have it on bed right what you can
do there she go so what do you guys all
do that's so great every storm
jerk does if I ever call you jerk